is
[Applause]
wow we're back are you mad this is the
new team oh yeah me and chris we're
going to take over now
and welcome to the waffle the waffle
what they call it i don't know man
that's what i'm saying harry why is it
called the waffle you can work it out
yourself yeah what did that just say
no you didn't
start
where is that from
that's why i was curious about this
whole freaking buzzer man we had to
swear on the show wait what did he just
say well i swear on this show
today now it's here i'll be the ball
game yeah
so today's guest
yeah is one of the old school dons then
oh get me comedian he's been in the game
still in the game he does his thing
still i've seen him air in there
because this is the first show so we
don't know whether we're going to call
it a waffling team it depends on the
person what do you think
what's going on bro you know i never
drink gingerbread every night
are you happy yes and no
a strong seven why'd you say strong
seven you know we're here today i'm here
with the lads
yeah and then there's just something
missing yeah i just want to mention
yeah that's what i'm asking for i just
want to mention man and um
that's a lot you're asking for though
yeah we're not thinking about it
what are your steps to get in this
mansion
uh you know just keep grafting and
that's that's where it's not a tent
until i'm in that mansion as a tent yeah
yeah okay so
so would you say that you're grafting in
the right way to get towards that
mansion right now
or would you say that you could do more
i could do more but i'm doing with what
i with what i've got at the moment you
know what i'm saying and then obviously
yeah yeah with the links and that
hopefully you get more links but i need
you know with the links i've got
hopefully i can be in that mention i'm
not joking about this mansion you know
you're magical chris
and you know that happened with drake
drake said he used to drive fastest
mansion every day and look at it until
we finally got something just like that
you get me
everyone's got that little room like the
boom boom how would your mansion look
furthermore my mansion oh don't get me
started you're from nigeria yeah i'm
from nigeria bro why y'all
[Applause]
1875.
yeah because it sounds like you now yeah
it's 1882.
no it's 1867. but i'm always the closest
bro i must be getting i was the closest
i said 1867.
you said it after your teeth 1865.
i don't want to question it i won that
bro what did you say it's 1869.
see i'm closest because i eat ketchup
all the time
tell
the reason why you've got it right is
because he eats a lot of ketchup
do you think that you could ever reach
tendon because when you get to 10 you
won't be satisfied so do you think that
you will ever reach 10
no
because there's always more to reach you
know what i'm saying so um once you've
got the mansion you want something else
there's always something to chase to get
in this land and there's always a
problem in this life as well once you
get out one there's another one once you
get into a victory you want another
victory do i mean so so do you think you
can never be satisfied then in like no
i'll never mind i'm an engineering bro
what about you you think you could ever
be satisfied yeah of course yeah yeah
man well my kids are good i'm good
didn't it that's how i look at it that's
a good way to look i can't really sit
there and bug about myself
i mean i'm doing all right i'm okay
everything's moving i'm still making
peace man's happy kids are healthy
that's nice mommy's good you know what i
mean it's nice do you have kids one man
yeah we'll have kids yeah how many um i
want three so they can all fit in the
car yeah all for the same woman yeah
from the same time
i'm trying to do this properly
yeah i'm trying to find that i'm trying
to find her so what's your ambitions the
ambitions i've got many bro you know
what i'm saying what's your ambitions
um just doing films and that yeah i mean
films like when i was young i used to
watch people like will smith the rock
like this
movies and even the tyrese i mean i was
like i want to do that bear movies like
just not just what the baby biting yeah
and you know like movies here yeah
they're always about like stabbings and
selling drugs and that i want to do like
a movie like this okay look like a
comedy like a proper comedy like you get
like a barbershop scene yeah yeah yeah
it's not every day like seeing blood and
what's your views on um yeah what's your
views on um not to be disrespectful to
anyone but what are your views on top
boy their sick is sick i think
everyone's moving sick i'm still going
to watch it regardless but i just feel
like a lot of
movies or
dramas is about that in it dude i'm
saying like look at kevin hart like he's
doing stuff like jumanji and then what
about this one why can't we do that i
mean why can't we do like batman than
that dude i'm saying it's not every day
like some guy on the floor like oh my
god like we're trying to get out here
to life
there's too much to be done
why can't we do tarzan on that yeah i'm
saying there is a place forever
yeah what made you want to be this
person you are today no it was by
accident oh yeah yeah it was right now
well obviously i think the lord didn't
it for well i mean of course it was by
accident yeah
i love one
like people that know me from like 2012.
i used to tweet in capitals like and i
used to get very tweets and i always
said how you
was that from when you started
yeah i was on twitter i wasn't even
doing comedy i was just i'm just like
typing in cackles
you get me then people started coming
my followers started increasing then i
had like 5 000 followers just from
events
then i started doing like jokes on my
instagram because i was silly i was
always silly like from school like from
out just being silly in it i didn't know
that strangers would find me funny as
well when i was posting on that i used
to get bare comments in it so i took off
my instagram of private i took it off
private in it then bare random people
started like tagging each other in it so
i was like oh
something's happening oh like oh i can
make strangers laugh oh it's long so i
carried on doing they carried on doing
it then i started getting stopped on the
road and i was getting scared i was like
people are stopping me and that then one
day i was sitting in my kitchen
then i was like
fam should we just do this like
that
let's do this
the man just started posting them
posting and i'm posting when did you
start that what what was it 2014
14
2014 i started this year nice yeah like
the first time started following him i
was like uh krypton conan sick yeah then
then from there then i went on twitter i
quickly went on twitter
yeah i followed him on twitter
carried on carried on just yeah bro and
then man just carried it on away from
here from south london yeah south london
which part
like lambeth lamborghini yeah boys so
you grew up at stockholm brothers
sisters yeah one brother i've got one
sister yeah i was a young girl i'm the
oldest oh you're the oldest yeah
what's it like being an older brother
bro being that endurance is long because
i'm not from your culture but how how is
the oldest brother in a nigerian culture
um
was he always perceived as a joke of him
when he was in like primary school
like just or did it come later on in
life not from primary school man um
yeah man i was silly people yeah
right i just get sent out just be silly
like still like show my bum and that
there's class
i used to do like silly stuff like that
why is my shirt yeah that's not that's
not all things something yourself
but that's not really a nigerian
now if the teacher leaves if the teacher
walks out and that goes to like go get a
get out tea or
house
[Laughter]
what secondary school did you go to what
was it like that i went to a secondary
school in like oval like cricket grounds
hello yeah boys
no i didn't play cricket
i hate cricket
tennyson really rough yeah man it was
right never got bullied no i got bullied
here and there and then i bullied a
couple back okay yeah
yeah yeah i would say like my primary
school was much calmer and that then i
went to a secondary school and at the
time when i was in year six the
percentage for the school was high
so it was like 96 percent or something
much like that so obviously what
violence no no it's no in grades bro
okay cool no i needed to know you threw
me off when you started talking about
this stuff
oh
they were fighting in my estate so that
wasn't happening so we went up the road
and it was a good the grades were good
so we went there but when i went into
the playground in year seven
the greys and the the violence were
basically 96 as well blood you get me
oh it was a different from the water bro
the playground is a boy school in south
london bro just
bro the jokes as well the jokes were
yeah was your school mixed no it's mixed
now because the school was too rough
because because there's
not much else to do as well all you do
is probably cuss each other a lot in it
bro
like bro random fight people are doing
the most weirdest things in school bro
like it was funny bro there's some
people that were in second school that
should be doing comedy as well straight
they don't even know they don't even
know that that's imagine a lot of people
are natural comedians but they don't
know how to express themselves of course
did you have like much beef in with
other schools in your area as well like
oh 100 bro it was like this man coming
down the dismantle what was you did you
back it for your school was you in the
background
no i was never brought i was never that
good
i was never a front liner bro yeah yeah
i was it was mainly office it was yeah
it was mainly a follow back eating right
there's something going on over there
okay
like i'm not the main guy bro my mom
will beat me bro like i can't be the
main man but i'm nigerian bro i would
say i was walking with people that would
do that thing but i would i was never
never the guy
yeah
i was a good guy bro
like i might have my naughty ways but
i'll be naughty with bare people not
knowing on my own yeah
caught up with others like it's not my
thing i'm in trouble with others
did you get good grades in the second
half bro i've got three gcses bro
that's the way honor what was wrong with
this
well i've got three
is they were all in ict as well
having nigerian parents hey my name is
i took the long way home bro yeah i took
the long way home bro obviously i went
to college and i've done some research
and i got my math got my english
is that when you decided to back up or
do you just felt like you needed to do
it or was it just mal was an average
student i'm saying that if i failed i
failed and then if i passed it's like a
scrape like
a c like it's never a b or a like you
just it's a c or d or something like i'm
around them sides you get me so that's
what was happening if i got a b bro like
bro we're going kfc we're getting
mcdonald's yeah
yeah
in primary school i was smarter though
then i was saying secondary school it
just started just kind of downhill like
crowds or something so it was never like
any of this social comedy stuff not in
your nand i went to drama school though
can i ask you a quick question they say
like in a lot of african households
they're quite strict in they kind of
told you what they want you to do to be
honest with you
we just didn't i didn't want to do
anything
[Laughter]
you know the gcses are coming up when
you're nine into year ten and that i
picked drama but only six people picked
drama
do you get it so that got scrapped so i
had to pick
that so now i'm picking history now and
that
i'm picking ice cream
do you think that held you back from
being like that person early dogs if you
know what i'm saying because you know
there's a lot of you to them what follow
fashion or follow yeah they're they're
trying
or they're gang and they know everyone
want to be themselves i want to be that
guy yeah
i'm following these man so i'm not gonna
do that you see it because your whole
circle could [ __ ] you up there might be
a ride out in school or something
probably you didn't come to the park
so you're not bad like you didn't come
to virginia you weren't dead yeah you
weren't there you didn't roll
you get me so then from there when
you're talking about what you're holding
or whatever it's like those flowers you
didn't come virgins when it was kicked
i i know them stories so yeah there's a
lot of following and follow buddies and
that like i was i was one of them bro
like because there's 20 man or 50 man
i'll be in there because it's 50 man but
if it was three man i'm not going man
i want to see what happens but i don't
want to hear no one can hold me back i
don't want it
no i don't want to hurt no one bro do
you get it not there
[Music]
it was not near to woolwich
so can you imagine the madness the
smilers don't ramp they come in packs
crowds you get me my brother in the
school
i had beef in one of the somali news
blood
everyone from the school foot they could
go
bear in mind somalians don't care who
the [ __ ] you are you know yeah
if you're wrong
if you're rolling just know you're with
them then and they think your enemy you
understand so batman's gotten to see
while going for the beef blood that same
thing you just said i went there and i
had to see while gwan don't touch no one
that same thing happened to bear man but
bear man got hurt you feel me so even
when you want to go see something
sometimes yeah it's better you just fall
back
because you get yourself involved with
[ __ ]
i'm to go too far with it but some of
them eat the wood
and they're a different person
i've seen man look at me and i didn't
look again
like i've looked at him he's looked at
me
and i said he's chewing it and i said no
i just said no my whole mind told me
you're shut down right now
yeah i started looking around to like
where can i go to go like i need to go i
don't want to be here now because you
look like you're on to me like a [ __ ]
um
a rottweiler or something ready
phones were getting stolen in school one
guy from brixton came into the school
but he wasn't a student
don't imagine this
guy he's not a student you know this guy
was probably like some road man or
something
he's jumped into the playground by
lunchtime everyone
someone
wore a blazer
blazer whoa and robbed
phones bro and he tried to come the next
day and then obviously he's going around
the schools to some guy like around like
bro the guy had like four teeth in his
mouth and that roll
they were done then he got then he got
clocked because
bear members from our school were moving
back like an ocean so he was in the
playground on his own in it oh so
definitely see many people
do you know the capital madrid
why do you go like furthermore don't try
that [ __ ] he tried to say it like saying
well done it's like
i was waiting to know before i actually
know like bro before he was going to say
this is
[Music]
the teachers
is
i studied media and communications you
still want to do that or did you just no
it was all a parent's thing but this is
the uni is when the comedy is now kicked
in oh you start meeting other people in
it yeah started doing comedy and that
then i was failing in uni i was in uni
for like five years bro rotted bro
bro i was doing that
yeah
i thought that mama was gonna come out
of that
hanging out with the eight-year-old
[Laughter]
when i got to uni and i had my first
like what's it called lecture on that
bro man sitting in there a man didn't
know what my man was saying
like he's changed from college he's like
what is this what is this what are you
casting okay why are you casting this
course
so i felt that
i wasn't taking this seriously and the
bear freshers and that going coventry
coming back busting nuts and that bro i
failed it cool came back done done
another year i said i'm changing my
coastal media they let me in done that
failed the first year didn't take it
seriously then from there i just said
yeah let me patent it because the the
peas are piling yeah
there was a family
forcing it of course the teacher was
still in that probably end up with one
of the students that was in your
electorate
people are all finishing they're all
going second third here
like what are you
sure the reason i was failing as well
because i was having better shows as
well i was having shows shows like
comedy shows so
and what what type of comedy shows were
they at unis
so did you stand up comedy sketch the
whole story yeah i was hosting an event
i was hosting bear i was having fair
shows bro hot fishing bear uni's bro
hollywood
hosting just like love like love shows
valentine's and that
acs
shows and not studying and just caring
about comedy i'm looking at my instagram
i didn't care about the language yeah
i'm just trying to do another video but
i've got an assignment like me and my
mom were arguing on that so oh man
i was like i want to do comedies like
well you gotta finish what would you get
so
yeah man i've done that now we're doing
this full time that's good man you get
me would you get paid for those shows
yeah but the shows the shows them days
but they weren't much though they were
like three hundred four hundred that
john i mean match your show yeah matt
that's still good though yeah
how old was she when he was doing that
flat 21 what was the numbers of people
what was the audience the audience was
brought to uni road
he was carrying 500 600 bro yeah that
was a lot of people bro like i got it i
don't know when i had my first show and
then i used to like fart but like
because i'm next i used to start farting
in that in the corridor
like fighting out on the stage and that
yo
then everyone's all screaming in there
relationships
for eight years oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i've
been singing
out of no girl nothing all this time
told her ah bro i was just having girls
i was seeing and uh is there a reason
why you're single for so long um i feel
like i'm just too busy in it i don't
have not time for that it will look like
man's too selfish so when you're not
planning to have kids because you know
time is ticking just told me i don't
want you men to be like sitting there
and being like i can't even do the
things i want to do because i'm not
doing it as i would have been do i mean
and i've started early i would say i
started 21
so
i'm just saying wait the fun i have with
my kids now and i've still got the
energy to keep doing it it's great so
i'm just letting you not know don't
leave it too late that's what i was just
that's what i wanted to say because
you're coming to my brain like wrong i
don't want magnet to be sitting there
and i'm like mike swan what's man yeah
i've got the kid what
once you have that baby that feeling
that moment it's that time that
everything what happens at once
i know what i'm talking about because
i've been in it yeah you see it once man
have that moment i understand no one can
tell man once i get a girl and all of
that woman i want to have that first
child out you go again mm-hmm second
child out go again oh you like that yeah
bro and then when you're saying that the
whole we're all older than that it's all
in one like once man hits like what fray
fade or something
done that's it
you get me get out yeah the kids get in
the car yep
artists right now eddie k track
um
what about millions though not [ __ ]
millions is hard millions i thought he
was one of the top ones i like meeks
money
he heard him yeah
manchester united
that's what stands out for me
yeah i don't care about lyrics like that
yeah i like flow
what you're gonna do next after that
flow yeah what are you going to do after
that
see i'm a lyric man i like lyrics too
but flows do you play
ball if i hit man's bar and it sounds
mad i'm like what did he just say i like
lyrics if it's like krypton conan not
like lyrics for any artist oh that's
specific when is the art it's doing
lyrics you listen
to it there's certain [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay this is the lyric guy let's sit
down and listen yeah yeah you've not
ever been watching that versus the clash
ring
locks and um
you see that we've just done that yeah
someone says that if we had an english
versus no one can chat to giggs's
catalogue he's catalogued with would you
all these but we're talking about
artists albums or music music if you
want to stand there and play a tune for
a tune yeah who's spinning you could go
with him
apart from maybe not even dizzy law
school crazy tits
he was a madman as well but that was
that's that that was our camps though
that was the days when we never really
made tunes though i didn't even talk
about gigs like that unless it was a
rapture where everyone's out yeah it
kicks his heart
nines that's what i'm saying
well my new nines but
them time there it was always in the
borough
so it's only going to be what's down the
road from me and i'm illusion giggs was
down there well i was listening to giggs
from you see it like what nine's though
has hit nine's ain't got hits like geeks
now this is big it's big what geeks
is different
that's why i'm trying to get there
things would you already listen to
records
obviously i'll i'm from lucha minnesota
so obviously my people i listened to
back then was just in the circle i was
in that ice listen to papoose
big l i would go american with it like
that was where i listened my ears were
on biggie tupac yeah
after uni
did you work
in a normal job like retail or what jobs
did you have no i haven't worked for
them six years now bro is it right
so even at uni that's a big movie i
wasn't working bro yeah i used to work
in august that was my last job yeah
[Music]
but i was wiping people's asses bro
that's right
that's what i'm going to mention on
there but yeah nice to be a care worker
i swear
big man bro
for work this is what i'm saying you
can't please everyone like i'll be in
august and someone blacks brother you're
a real brother you know that fam man
didn't even know you were and then you
will get someone else coming in then you
work
put you down
wow
i thought you were yeah you're not that
good
what are you putting it trying yeah well
you know i highly rate you because you
just don't give a [ __ ] you know
i'll get
australia china no
no
china
no russia no man i went no no way it was
my turn
thank you
russia
[Music]
no i knew i was waiting for you to
finish your turn it was meant to be my
turn
what was your funniest moment in your
life like what was the funniest thing no
that sounded funny that happened to me
though don't say about the bump thing
again no don't do it because i love a
naked thing though it's what happened no
obviously
when i was in year five and that they're
streaming
city at five you remember back then yeah
bro because this day was experienced way
back you know this day was embarrassing
bro
i was 10 years old yeah five
man just finished swimming and then off
after swimming is here six
there's a toilet yeah so so man's in the
toilet i finished swimming out wet
i put the towel on the floor so man's
naked there's no one there there's a
door on the side but it doesn't go all
the way to the bottom so one of the year
sixes i've grabbed my towel from the
other side
so when i finish wearing now i'm just
looking for my towel oh [ __ ]
just standing right naked in the
is that from when
[Laughter]
yeah because you're always known for
that that there's his bread in my
primary school
so from there the man just called him
skidmark that was his name
and if i see him today we will call
y'all that's kidding me
remember you're lucky you didn't get i
was i was i had a little thing in
primary school um
mine had a audi belly button in it okay
on my out he looked like a sausage in it
bro my belly button look like that's
what it is you look like a d bro
you get me oh [ __ ] so man used to
schedule six isn't that i was in
reception chasing you at sixes
you're [ __ ] crazy
people
those are like one of my biggest
insecurities i don't know like like
swimming on that would you eat it back
off my top and then the belly button and
yeah oh so that was your biggest thing
yeah like i'll be standing there like
that with the audi and that yeah they're
like my biggest insecurities me i used
to have tits because i was fat
doing some mad crosses in that last
they're crossing it like they're fat bro
like crossing the ball
yeah bro
sweating like out here like so like
everyone should knock me out and prime
me
that's where it started that was the
reason why i lost weight my mum bought
me a dog it was for my brother it was
meant this is his birthday and i wanted
the dog what was dying which is so weird
they said that does not going to live
long you get them because back in the
day you could go into the dog shop and
get your dog like that you get me just
pay for the dog there and then get out
it's a chinese type of dog but the dog
was meant to not have fur but my one did
to get me blood and they were saying yes
a bit weird i think this one's gonna die
or i'll somehow add attraction to the
dog the dog likes man brought the dog
home i've took the dog to the park room
boy and
my mom always used to say to me bring
the lead in it and always keep him on
the lead so i said yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna go park i was about ten nine
because i was only going to the closest
part to my house which was like three
four minutes away but i took the dog to
the part let off the lead like some
idiot thinking yeah go and run let it do
its team friends stick
playing with it another dog's appeared
and my dog just ducked out
blood i was in the park barling crying
trying to work out to bring the dog back
mom's gonna bust my ass when i come back
without the dog bear thing's bad i was
in the park for a good like 30 40
minutes trying to search for my dog
telling people have you seen the dog
have you seen the dog boom got home
where's the [ __ ] dog boy
dogs at the [ __ ] door wiggling his
tail looking at me
and i was so confused how my dog felt
his way back but he must know the route
yeah but the dog was at the door
so pissed black i'm so angry but yeah it
was that feeling where i went through i
said [ __ ] bro yeah that i nearly lost my
dog today and i nearly got my head bust
today but
after all that nothing it happened to my
knowledge
but the dog the more of the story was
the dog was the reason why i lost the
weight because the dog i'm always
running after the dog playing with the
dog
[Music]
bro like noticing as the years were
going by i went secondary school i was
the fastest in my year
mental boom first race i had 100
[ __ ] blood i was off never knew i was
that fast never ever knew year seven
yeah nine who's your top five comedians
then therefore go and give it to chris
tucker yeah he's one of them therefore
go give it to dave chappelle
oh eddie murphy how can i forget
andy murphy's probably the hardest he's
foundation he's the hardest okay that's
what i was watching that's what i used
to
like watch when i was young in it that's
why we're here today like these are the
things i used to stare at for a time
explanation i used to stare right here
and rewind it yes bro
i was weird bro see now look my favorite
is jamie foxx like if you check his
records jamie foxx is hella funny bro he
sells he used to do hard comedy stand-up
shows right do impressions
yes
he's gone platinum in music he's got
platinum in his comedy he's got oscars
he is there's nothing in the talent
world that jamie foxx ain't done if you
check his gravity he's got more than
most of the black comedians out there
right now no one can touch him but the
reason why he's not seeing us the most
because he went straight into kind of
serious filming after so it's like that
was hard yeah that's what i'm saying you
got awesome
yeah um
why do we like those movies
so much compared to uk movies i think i
could answer that now you know because
that was one question i always thought
about yeah
why am i so adapted to this where we
reacting lightly
in the hood we really like it
what's friday
i think it's something to do with the
fact that it just relates to something
in our lives but or just us being you
know i mean as black people over in
england when we were growing up we
didn't have much black actors on the
team
everything was going straight i was
always drawn to that
yeah so because that's all we had as our
heroes to look up to or our funny people
eddie murphy when he first passed who
the [ __ ] is this guy you get i'm trying
to say we follow eddie then we start
following other americans
yeah they didn't have anyone for us and
i actually
compared them to us yeah the english
don's i can't thank you jamie foxx eddie
murphy
um i'll say mike
um he's [ __ ] hilarious ricky gervais
oh yeah dave chappelle and ricky [ __ ]
gervais like the way he can do his films
he just talks to you like this and
like how we're talking now but it's an
actual film and he can make a story the
man doesn't seem like he's scripted then
his last stand that was funny he's
called it was it humanity is it humanity
and then his show called afterlife
rally's [ __ ] hilarious the characters
yeah david brent brothers that is one
guy i love ricky gervais special power
what would it be being invisible wow
what would you do bear girls would be
waking up no panties
don't do that again
[Music]
what would you do if he was invisible
then no invisible just robbed the bank
you're invisible money's not oh you
couldn't appear how are now you taking
that out in the bank
explain it to me no you can go invisible
then visible when you want you can
but the money can't i'm walking out of
it oh well back in the air like this
everyone's watching everyone's watching
this bag guy invisible bro imagine if
you're invisible
how's this [ __ ] back in the cold
we've been floating
what the [ __ ] is this yeah yeah yeah oh
i'm holding it tight invisibly
and i know any random person that's
holding it they can't get it there's a
force
bro don't see these niger movies they've
been doing themselves
how's it
oh you can splash it bro i said yeah the
one thing if i had a power here i would
you can't catch me
the impossible you're on the ground
running
i don't know you're there because if the
bag's blowing my knot like you said
you're gonna hold it before i'll whack
the other side of man and mom will drop
the bag what year did world war ii start
unfinished
1960
no no 1940 to 1945
i'll give you that i'll [ __ ] off
1939 to 1945. okay i'll wait
so mike what's next man nothing
no i've got loads of like filming on
that coming out the fort silence you
said yeah
yeah but that's what i wanted to hear
like i wanted to do movies bro so if
there's any movies guys please don't
call us cool so listen mike yes bro love
for being the first member thank you for
being on this show
right now this is the waffle as you can
see yeah it comes called the waffle and
you chat your business
you waffle in it i think i waffled the
most though but
if
if he's comfortable with everyone else
it's fine
i don't know
i'm still trying to work it out because
it's very funny and then moments you get
sad then it's a make sure that that's
yeah
yeah so it could be the high loading
they said of waffle but the high loading
that sounds good i know i don't know i
don't know the high level but we'll
sleep with waffle because harry is the
guy behind this camera and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] what we say
yes and so big up mike man thank you
again
again all right and we are out
[Applause]
you